-Oh, I got to give props
to the hair and makeup.
This is -- Explain this.
You posted this.
-[ Chuckling ] Oh, yeah.
-Can you zoom in a little bit?
-Yeah.
-So, explain what's happening
here, 'cause...
-Okay, so, Vivian Baker --
she's actually nominated
for an Academy Award
this year for "Bombshell."
-Congrats, Vivian.
-She's amazing -- Vivian Baker.
-Oh, yeah, it was great.
-So, she did
this really rough look,
because my family
has experienced
a lot of tragedy.
-Yeah.
-And so, anyway,
she did this really rough look
at the beginning,
and this is once
I sort of clean up.
But when I posted it,
people were saying,
"Wow, Blake bravely show
what she looks like
before and after her makeup."
[ Laughter ]
And...
-They -- They think you look...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
They think this is what you
look like with no make up on?
Well, this is two sides.
-Yeah.
-This is -- This is
a partisan issue, here.
-Yeah.
-There are two sides.
Some people think that's what
I look like without makeup,
which I find very offensive,
because that takes an hour
for her to make
me look like that.
This also takes an hour for her
to make me look this good.
So, like, I'm sort of like
vacillating
between, like, you know,
my vanity,
which is, like, wanting to,
you know, be like,
"I don't actually
look like that,"
and then also, like,
being a feminist
and being like...
-"Why can't I?"
-..."Why do we expect women
to wake up looking like this?
This isn't realistic that you
wake up this beautiful."
-Sure.
-But I would like
people to believe
that I wake up that beautiful.
[ Laughter ]
-If we're just being honest.
-Yeah, my feminism
sort of goes down.
-Come on, buddy,
it's not that crazy.
-Don't set unrealistic
expectations for women.
-But I saw that, and I go, "Oh,
my gosh, this is unbelievable."
-You're like,
"That's what she looks like
every time she comes over
with Franny."
-Every time I have a play date,
that's what she --
this is exactly
what you look like.
She's like, [Rough voice] "Hey,
I'm droppin' my kids off."
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, let yourself in
when you get back."
[ Normal voice ]
Kid's 5 years old.